hello everyone matt here from code tech
and tutorials welcome to another episode
of design patterns today we're going to
be looking at the command pattern really
i'm just going to show you how to code
it up in c
plus and
just explain it as i go command pattern
is very common in
code in general might even use it
without even realizing it sometimes but
and it's also not that complex of code
generally so in general
anything any object you create to
either do something or pass uh to
something else to do something is
probably along the lines of a command
now let's look at the uh this sort of
standard for making commands and how to
program one uh in theory
as you can see here i've got a new uh
folder in our design patterns project up
on github link below and we're gonna do
all the code in this command uh main is
empty right now there's the c make for
it we've got that all added at the top
level to make so we're going to close
this cmx we shouldn't need anything else
all right first thing we're going to do
is just make a header and we're going to
call this header just command is fine
command dot h and in this class we want
to do some base definitions of what a
command is so we're going to have a
command interface this way we can build
commands and use some polymorphism power
to process any variety of commands so
it's pretty standard to do something
like this last let's just do uh we'll
call it base con or just command i'm
going to call it i command i like the
idea of putting eyes in front of
interface classes
just a personal preference it's starting
to grow on me a bit and that just uh
means we want to have some pure virtual
function here but we do want to do the
standards for uh virtual our virtual
classes that is just make a constructor
like so it doesn't need to do anything
it just needs to exist and then we want
to have some sort of function here
that
we override i'm just going to call it
execute that's pretty standard
const make it equal zero so cost because
it's not going to change anything it's
just going to do some process do the
work in theory the command or maybe
it'll send it off somewhere we'll see
we'll get to that but equal zero of
course to make it an interface so this
is a pretty standard interface
and uh this will come in handy a little
later as you'll see all right so we have
an interface for a command was a command
look like well it can look
like anything here i'll code up a simple
basic one for you
let's just say we have a command to
print string command
this is going to be
very very basic public command inherit
right from
um
i command
and
in this one
okay so it's print string so we want to
have whatever you're operating on you
probably
want to keep in some sort of storage
here you don't necessarily have to you
probably want to you'll see why here in
a second so privately we're just going
to if we're printing a string we're
probably going to have a string that
we're saving
i'm going to call it payload because
that's the way i saw it in an example
and i like that word public
for the next part okay so when people
make this command they have to construct
it right we want to
make uh the constructor very specific
because we don't want people to move
around with this and do awkward things
with it we could even go as far to say
that this is a final class don't further
inherit from this command but that's not
really necessary at this point
but essentially we want a constructor
and we don't want to allow people to
construct it any other way and so they
need to pass in whatever the command
requires we're going to require some
data which is going to be the payload
and we'll just set immediately
so this way when you create this print
string command you need to create it
along with
whatever the payload is and then the
execute function should operate on that
and do whatever your little uh command
does you need override here yep in this
case we're just going to uh we're going
to print it
just do it like this
and you can include whatever data you
want to include in your execute function
in this case hey we're just printing a
string
maybe it's maybe it's a log
command for example maybe that makes
more sense
and then you could do other special
stuff with this command you know it gets
a little more complicated just making a
simple prints very simple but not very
useful but what if you for example have
command that's a logger and anytime you
create it you got to pass it in a string
and it just logs that and then maybe
somewhere else you add in another little
function here that allows you to change
where it logs to like maybe you want it
to print to a file instead of standard
out then you could modify up the slug
command and have it do all that and boom
there you go something semi useful there
if you were to expand a little bit so
that's a little theory for how you would
do um just the little simple command so
let's go ahead and call it let's go to
our domain make sure we include command
and we'll don't worry we'll get to a few
more interesting examples later but this
simple use is sometimes all you need so
we might as well go all in on that so we
want to make a log command it wants some
kind of string and let's pass it
this is my message log
that should figure it out
we probably need to include string here
yeah well we need to include a string
not necessarily there but it's customary
to put them at the top but if i were
working on this as a separate program i
would have this be in its own file
personally so that's why i'm kind of
doing includes below it but it doesn't
matter that much
you can follow your standards and not
code the exact same way i code it's fine
all right
so there we go that should all compile
that should in general work including
command should get us a string in io
stream
so there we go
so when we create this it doesn't do
anything now we got to call the execute
on it
on
also initializing incorrectly variable
needs name i don't know it's called lc
and there we go so if we run this let me
just go to uh
and there
yep that's it and let's go ahead and
give that a run as you can see we got
the message to log okay
so there we go there's a simple symbol
command but usually they get a little
more complicated you probably keep your
logger simple enough
and uh you know expand it to switch
between file or console want or
maybe if you add a graphical interface
later you could also change this log to
also print to the screen somewhere on
your graphical interface as well so you
could have it like you know it's a nice
little contained log command that you
want to
add to your logger you modify one area
of code that's critical you modify one
area of code to do this that's
like super important in these design
patterns i think a thing that might get
overlooked a lot is that these patterns
are here not because
they're gonna
they're gonna try to make a good way to
work this basically if you use these
type of patterns your code becomes a lot
more easily maintainable and that's a
big reason
after going through a lot of these i
realized personally i need to refactor a
lot of stuff in my game engine and a lot
of the code i was working on previously
i could make in a more maintainable way
so
if you don't know these patterns you can
still get stuff done you'll just
probably accidentally make it not very
maintainable it's basically what happens
in the long run that's my takeaway so
far anyway i'm curious to see what you
guys think or experience but anyway
let's get to the second part and make a
more complicated command because this
log one was an example of a simple
command
so we'll just put that example
and let's make an example of a more
complicated command and to be fair when
i was talking about adding all that
special stuff about switching what it
logs to that sort of makes this a
complex command if you do all that right
here it's real simple because it
literally just says one thing all right
well
there's also another big difference
about complex commands and obviously
that makes sense well here the thing is
let's go back to the simple command and
talk about why it's simple real quick
there in general with a command you need
something to receive the command
now in this case what's receiving the
command is generally the console out
which is part of the standard library so
we don't need to do a whole lot of work
because we can just use that it's like
hey the receiver here's the receiver oh
the console is going to receive it
that's that's what so no need to do a
whole lot of work now but if you have
custom stuff going on like for example
some rendering logic or some game logic
might be passing this command to some
other object known as the receiver
so instead of just your c out you would
have something else so let's work up an
example of a receiver now the receiver
is basically some class in your uh in
your code that does some of your main
important logic and it will carry out
some of these commands alright so let's
make a receiver a theoretical conceiver
let's see for a receiver now i'm just
saying words
now what does this do right you gotta
you gotta decide that we could add a
bunch of different stuff to this
probably in the long run you'll have a
lot of stuff in here like for example
uh if we wanted to modify this to
instead of
actually print maybe we could attach it
to a receiver that has a print command
and that way
you know let's not do that
uh let's do a slightly different example
um
let's do process a
now it needs to take in something it
either needs to take in
the command itself
or just some important data associated
with process a so we'll just stick with
strings for now and we'll call it
ross let's say stuff
sure that works and we'll do the same
thing just a process b and a process b
stuff and
these will you know based off of what
data you pass in it's probably not going
to be string in your case because you
know strings good for printing and
maybe getting keywords but you know when
you get to more efficient stuff you're
often working with specific structures
and states so you might pass in that
whole state structure or something like
that but uh yeah just to give you an
idea of where to go from here if you
were to expand it for now let's just
stick with all right we'll just say
uh receiver is working on and we could
just say
rock a stuff and same here
b stuff
um maybe we want to say the function
name too sure we'll do it just to make
it a little more clear but essentially
you would have as many processes as you
want or as you need
with taking in as many different things
as you want and your receiver is
probably going to be called like i don't
know something else it's not necessarily
going to be called a receiver is the
point but
it could really want it to be
and yeah so just more
more business logic i don't know
supposed to do here okay so now that we
have a receiver this is going to expand
how our commands can work beyond this
simple pattern that's where things get a
little more interesting so let's start
out some of the same way this is kind of
also where you get to delegation because
sure you have command comes in command
gets delegated and how it works
internally in your receiver is totally
up to you if you want to put it on a on
a stack or cue and process them one at a
time you can do that
if you want to have certain ones create
their own threads and do things
internally you can do that now so it
gets uh
this is why it's so useful is you can
basically you can basically design a
program around these commands and have
your
in it's a nice way to separate out like
your interface of what you're allowed to
do along with the internal
of how those things are handled all
right so let's make a com a more complex
command uh what do we call this i don't
know i don't have a really good name for
it here
yeah we'll just call it complex command
out
and it's going to inherit from our
interface again as it is still a command
of course you might think of a better
name for the class here shortly but uh
this one we want to actually have
a receiver so let's just privately make
a receiver
pointer
receive but now why is it a pointer you
might ask well if it were its own object
then it would instantiate here and you
know we'd have an instance of the bit of
the business logic inside every command
definitely don't want that that's why
it's a pointer
because here we can point to the real
receiver or the receiver we want we
actually might have multiple receivers
we probably don't want to necessarily be
creating them in commands i guess you
could if you really want to but as
things grow it's going to get a bit
messy you probably just want
something running receiving
ready to go that you can say here's a
command have this receiver handle it all
right so that's private so we'll get to
that shortly and we can also you know if
you've got any associated data just like
we had a payload here
um we'd want those two so in our case
we're just going to have some strings
we'll just call these same
things these are not references and i'll
call it details down here but these
could be any struct related to what the
receiver can handle like this might be
if you're working on a renderer for
example this might be all the render
details or something or it might be
all the shader variables that need to
change as a pre-render or something
along those lines
but we're just going to keep them
strings here because it makes for an
easy quick example so publicly we also
want to do a very similar thing we want
to make a constructor
and make that the only constructor
that way they're forced to follow this
uh
class
all right so we need a receiver passed
in let's go ahead and delete all these
actually
so we definitely want to set the
receiver like you absolutely have to set
the receiver so it's a pointer
now there could be cases where this
might be better as a reference because
that would there be a bit of a guarantee
that the reference isn't known because
it still could be bad data though but
as a pointer it's assumed that someone
does the check beforehand
that it's not no or we could handle in
the constructor and throw or something
but we're not really gonna get too deep
into that right now because that gets
complicated personally i'd probably use
a shared pointer here i think that would
work great but i'm not going to do that
right now
and we also want what these process
details are so we just need to pass in a
couple strings
it's called a and b
or now
and then you just want to set all these
you can do them right in line here now
let's do it real quick i guess i'm going
to break it to a new line because it's
getting so long and just set these
strings like so just make it so that the
compiler knows how to do it in an
efficient highly efficient way well in
general but there we go now there's only
one way to make a complex command you
need to pass it a pointer to a receiver
and some details about
what the command is actually going to do
now what's the execute function going to
look like we do have to instantiate that
let's see if visual studio will help us
quick actions and refactoring implement
all pure virtuals for class complex
command will it work will it work
no
this has never worked for me i don't
understand why
but uh i don't know if something i'm
doing wrong or something visual studio
is doing wrong but i can literally never
get that feature to work i don't know
why it's even listed there
or if it works for other people let me
know does that work for you guys when
you go here and do the implement
pure virtual see right click on the
class quick actions in refactoring
implement all pure virtuals this never
works for me reason it failed that's why
i couldn't because it failed okay
that's the worst details ever
can you tell me why it failed anyway
side rant over let's make this execute
command so let's just overwrite it void
executants override and we basically
want to pass this along to the receiver
so we know the receiver set so we can
just go
receiver
and then call one of these functions
whatever one we need from the receiver
to do stuff well
you might need to you might want to
check these first before you call them
or you just pass them along directly and
say hey i got some process a stuff
process it
so however you want to set that up
personally i think it's a good idea to
keep the logic in the command as simple
as possible
and start doing all your more
interesting things in the receiver so
i'm not going to do any checks here i'm
just going to pass it along if the
internals want to throw the errors or
whatever notify us that the date it's
garbage they can't but
the complex command we're not going to
do that we're just going to pass along
the details and that's it so when this
runs
should use this receiver here it could
make it a little more explicit and put
the uh this keyword does since i guess
there's a potential that you uh
do multiple inheritance like you do
something like i don't know
log command right which is still going
to be about the same except
what if log command also has a receiver
then it's going to be like okay well
which which receiver are we using so
that's why this clears that up sometimes
but actually not necessary i don't think
here
let's revert this just wanted to give
you an example but that's why you might
use something like this i'm not going to
put it there i don't think it's it
doesn't make it any clearer in our case
it's fairly obvious that's that's the
one all right
so now if we instantiate a complex
command we also need a receiver let's go
ahead and do that okay
put down a few lines so we go
okay well actually we need to make a
receiver first receiver just make a
receiver called wreck it could be a
recorder you could send for example if
you were recording you could have a
receiver that you just send every a
picture of every frame and it saves that
and into like you know an mp4 or
whatever your recording is so
you could you know
send make a command as a recorder
just another thought example there but
anyway okay so you have a receiver
you can make it a pointer and do new and
delete if that's what you want to do but
if you're in the same scope here it's
not too big of a deal let's make a
complex command and
we'll just call it uh
cc for now now this one needs to be
instantiated with some stuff
uh there's we look at the constructor
that we just made we need a receiver
pointer a string two strings
all right so let's go ahead and do that
because it should not compile let's see
let's just hit play without giving a
thing
yeah oh wait what's up i might have
typed with something let's make this
code correct yeah this isn't going to
compile because this constructor is
wrong i don't know if this is a cascade
of errors from that or something else so
we're going to finish this all right so
it needs a receiver not string a string
b
just keep it that simple all right so
this wants a pointer so you can make a
a little reference there which will say
which will basically say a pointer to
the start of the data which is a pointer
so that's fine and uh yeah of course if
you made this pointer to begin with you
don't need to reference that reference
it doesn't turn it into a pointer it
just passes along a pointer
to the start of the data all right which
is what a pointer is so
we don't want to go too deep into that
you guys probably know all that already
it's more
a different subject but let's go ahead
and run this now and see well unless we
gotta call execute on this
so we can see the end code
so we'll get our basic log command and
then we should get some messages for
that last x there
okay we have some errors we need to fix
mainly this process this execute here
needs the details as they're set not the
ones in a different function that don't
exist
okay i've discovered that all these
errors stem from me spelling receiver
wrong essentially
so let's just spell receiver correctly
okay
there's our original one there we go
with process a process b that are being
passed into that complex command and
then passed to the receiver they attach
to so another cool thing about this is
you can change receivers on the fly
which is super cool of course you
probably want an interface for them if
you're making a bunch of them that way
this can be adaptively changed either
but just have one main one
that's fine but you could in theory set
some public functionality like change
receiver
and take in a new one
so mid program you could switch it up
like so
and if you're doing that
you probably want to
you know just make an interface and that
way you can have multiple receivers
that's uh it's kind of going down a
deeper route that
well still somewhat related to the
command pattern it's you know if you
need to do it you do it if you don't
ever need to switch commands and you're
good with the one you could just leave
it as it is
so
the point is you should be somewhat
comfortable expanding these or thinking
about what else you could do and that's
kind of the point um of of this series
too because if if you're having a hard
time going beyond the basic examples of
things and thinking of other things you
might be able to do
um you're you might be at a different
phase where you're not ready to hear all
this i guess it's it might be not
necessarily but uh i don't know
all right so that all works there's uh
one other thing i want to show you here
because um
yeah sure that's cool and sure you could
change receiver and call execute again
like i was talking about
if you want to work up that example and
try it out if you want to even add it to
this repo just make a full request and
i'll add it in that'd be cool
but the other thing i want to show you
is now
see these are kind of operated on
individually just in our main
usually you have some sort of i guess
what they call an invoker or this might
be
kind of what wraps all your core
business logic i guess and an invoker
typically handles a bunch of different
commands so you can set all of those uh
in my case for like my game engine for
example my main loop is somewhat of an
invoker so when i execute my my core
main loop it goes through a bunch of
stuff and does much stuff i'm actually
refactoring that currently
after going through a lot of the stuff
i'm starting to realize it could be
better so
let's make an example of an invoker um
i think i'm actually just gonna now
we'll put it at the bottom of command
you should probably have some different
header but let's just make an example so
broker we'll just call invoker what most
examples seem to use but this could
essentially be your your main
uh i guess
probably a loop or something you can
call it what you want but it invokes
things so it's going to invoke commands
basically now you want to privately have
all the commands it handles
so we might have command one command two
i don't know it's totally up to to how
your program runs
we could have a startup command
we could have a uh i don't know
mid command and we could have like an
exit command or a shutdown command or
something i guess it would be more like
on i don't know
you can name them as appropriate for
your stuff but in my case here i'm just
going to do these once so just on
startup
on mid would be like maybe your core
inner loop that goes over and over or
something
uh you might have a bunch of different
commands there around a while loop or
something uh
that uh you know may pass along to
receivers whatever is going on
so you'll need to maybe design receivers
because
uh the invoker doesn't necessarily hold
receivers i guess it could but that'd be
a little odd they're supposed to be
separate
all right that's enough for the private
variables so let's publicly just make it
make some stuff here
uh since these are pointers we actually
need to delete them when we shut down
now you would think the same way for
this complex command here
that you probably want to delete on
shutdown to but that's not the case you
actually don't because it does not own
the receiver
that's probably why it'd be good as a
shared pointer rather than a unique one
because actually this receiver is owned
by the parent process which in our case
is our main
it's got the receiver if we delete
receiver
when the this command goes out of scope
for example if we do this we
are removing this data when we shouldn't
be that's not good
uh
just an example there of why we don't
own the receiver here so maybe we should
even make a comment not owned probably
should be refactored to a shared pointer
that's my opinion
that would make it more maintainable but
if you don't watch the video and you
just look at the code you're not gonna
know well now you will i guess since
there's a comma
all right but in this case
we're probably gonna
own all these commands although not
necessarily but if you do own them you
need to delete them so we're gonna make
a deleter is the whole point here and
it's just gonna call delete on all these
when the invoker goes out of scope all
right that's taken care of um
so you could make a constructor for
invoker that takes the commands but
the thing is you might just want them to
be null sometimes sometimes you might
not want these to do anything so you
might not have a startup command so
you're like okay i don't want to force
it to be set what if we don't have one
or i guess you could have it default to
to null in your constructor and some are
forced to be set
but that's a decision for you to make in
your design how what you also could do
is you could just have functions to set
them like uh set
startup command and it would just take a
command that you pass it we'll do a
pointer here again
now these are going to be owned as you
can see since we're deleting that
claiming that we own them basically uh
so whatever we pass in here we probably
either want to construct in line
yeah probably just want to set
construct in line and you'll see that in
the main shortly but let's for example
just make these
set mid command set
shutdown command all right and these
will do basically as you expect we're
just gonna
we're just gonna copy pointers
there's probably a a better more
efficient method
but copying pointers is relatively cheap
it's not that big of a deal but just
keep in mind that hey if you're going
for maximum efficiency any general
tutorial you see anywhere needs to be
taken with a grain of salt
when explaining and teaching things
efficiency is nice
but sometimes it convolutes the real
lesson
that makes sense so a lot of people just
leave it out i'm trying to kind of
explain when i'm leaving it out that way
at least have an idea but uh yeah just
in general brain assault
all right so if you can set all the
commands now we just want to have an
operation that like runs them basically
this would be called this would probably
be called in a loop somewhere depending
on how you want to do it or maybe just
goes through it once
but
you can basically set up sets of
commands with an invoker is the nice
thing so let's just say
do you
do the work we'll call it that just a
generic public function here and it's
just going to call all of these that
exist so say
if on startup basically if it's not null
i guess i could make it more explicit
and not equal
actually i like using all lowercase null
pointer but you know you don't have to
put that in there you can just leave it
like that it's the same check if not
null
then we want to run it we want to run
the command
so you would just go say the same
command
and just call its execute method and
we'll just do that for all of these
basically so if they exist
we'll run their null nothing will happen
so there we go
so there's a nice little invoker there
now let's use it in our main to show as
an example and you'll see something
super cool here uh in this example
coming up and it's basically that while
this invoker
you know knows nothing it just has
commands you can make these either
simple commands like these log commands
so you could do that or you could make
them complex commands that have
receivers set up so
it's a pretty cool way to design your
program okay let's just go to this next
next one
invoker example
building
sub commands demo there we go so here we
of course need an invoker
and it takes three operations or three
commands so we need to build those
commands we can do them in line uh
that's new and it's gonna get a little
a little interesting but sure whatever
let's just make three log commands for
now and we can for example just say
starting up
mid
mid time
oh we can do some quick logs like that
oh i need to give invoker a name
obviously we'll call it invoke just
lowercase invoker and i've clearly done
something wrong oh yeah i didn't make a
concer you know i talked about making a
constructor that did this stuff but uh
we're not doing that in our case instead
we're going like we're making it so that
you can modify the invoker ally
with set these commands so this is what
we have to do since i talked about it
was stuck in my memory like i actually
did it and we'll just do these other
ones very similar fashion there we go
we've set all the commands now when we
call the invokers do the work we should
see these three logs now i'm pretty sure
our current logger let's take a look at
it oh it puts in new lines don't wait
yeah it puts in new lines so we should
see print string and then the whatever
and then a new line okay so let's go
ahead and run this so let's fix our
errors
right
we name these i command so we gotta make
sure we call these the right thing a
little syntax errors there i think
that's the only real error we had yeah
okay and there we go those are the first
two that we already went over this is
the one we were just going over and we
see we got a starting up mid time and a
shutting down we got all three
operations uh going on the invoker as
you can see as you go through your
program you could change up these
commands but you might have this like
you know what i would be doing probably
uh
i don't know it just depends what you're
making your command for but the invoker
essentially allows you to batch together
a bunch of commands and uh kind of
modify them as needed i guess i'll do
one more quick thing i'll just say okay
so what if our mid command we wanted to
have a receiver because we wanted we
didn't want to log we wanted to actually
do some real stuff so we could
pass in i don't know we've already built
this one in this complex command we can
just pass it in here actually now once a
pointer so we'd have to do a reference
and that would set it up and we should
get the message that this one does on
execute
so let's go ahead and do that now this
is already set up with the receiver and
everything so as long as the receiver
didn't go out of scope or something
we're fine all right let's hit play and
there we go we see now in the thing
instead of mid process we get receivers
working on it
so yeah i guess the whole point is that
you can uh
these invokers invokers well they don't
know about the receivers the commands
have them in them so you can really make
your code super modular with this kind
of setup in general there's uh there's
just a lot of places you can go from
here
and i think that's all i've got for this
video i hope you've enjoyed it huge
shout out to my patrons you guys uh have
really made a huge difference for me
continuing this sort of work and also a
huge shout out to uh
the biggest website that i found to be a
great resource for learning these
patterns and if you want to do
additional rating i would highly
recommend them i mean it's just this
refactoring.guru site i love their
explanations i love their code i think
they did an excellent job if you want to
understand
the command pattern more
they have code examples in c plus plus
mine is derived from that in this code
at least
and it really helped me with an
understanding
and of course you can just read about it
too they have just a pretty good
it's kind of long but yeah you know what
actually i will read through all this do
an audio recording of it and post it on
my patreon just as like a bonus so if
you just want to put on headphones and
hear me read all this from their site
subscribe as little as three bucks a
month and get random extra stuff like me
reading this whole command thing and
maybe that'll help you just kind of want
to sink in and let it sink in passively
uh
yeah i think that's all i got thanks
guys i'll see you next one